my name is anjali my father is a car
mechanic and my mother is a housewife
vishal
the background which these students come
from is very challenging so the need for
center was to provide an environment
which was conducive to academics
i used to fare from mathematics i used
to be like
this is the worst subject
so the problem was that the children
concepts in maths were not good one of
my friends pointed out this wonderful
resource called khan academy and the
children found it really useful welcome
to the video on basic subtractions
[Music]
i never thought gamification could
motivate children so much they have
become confident self-learners also
their english comprehension capabilities
has improved tremendously
whenever i used to have one doubt i used
to feel very shy asking teachers but
khan academy's videos are best because i
can play it how many times i want it
[Music]
so salsa was an inspiration to me
because he made the site and he made it
free of course and now i'm able to teach
my fellow students
i am in love with mathematics just
because of khan academy
these children are from low income homes
they stay in one room tenements where
four five people are staying together a
lot of parents have hardly studied or
are illiterate so that's the kind of
background these children come from
i always wanted to be independent
and education is the best way to do it
so it's all connected khan academy
prabhatsar and what i am today is just
because of both of these things
[Music]
where knowledge is free where the world
has not been broken up into fragments by
narrow domestic walls
into that habit of freedom my lord
let my country away
[Music]